the Joe Rogan experience hi
I wish we could tell you what we were
talking about and yeah we were talking
about Joey getting in trouble though he
just just texted me about it
how's Joey Diaz get in trouble with what
the MMA community MMA outlets there's
nothing to do well here's the thing
though
I see where they're coming from they're
they're journalists if someone says
something that [ __ ] outrageous about
what McKenzie Durin's derriere must he
said I think your ass smells great right
yes the comic uncle Joey said this yes
the Commodore girl Joey but I get it
I get where they would and then Vinny
Magalhaes back them up I get it
packed up Joey yeah he backed up Joey
says I feel like and tasty too
Thanks yeah yikes I get it I don't get
it that's Joey Diaz the great comic
who's commenting on a hot girl in the
UFC he is not a writer he's not a
journalist these riders have nothing to
do so they're like how can we get hits
let's talk about Joey Diaz right cuz no
one's reading any of our [ __ ] I agree
with you in some what but he definitely
did do it like it ain't a bat here's my
thing they could say whatever they want
about what he said but if he was your
friend and he texted you that you would
do what I did
I'll show you he [ __ ] texted me that
before tweet I love the Joey text now
Joey never would text message oh I hope
he doesn't keep the ideas as a full on
text busy he still calls though last
week most of the time he calls but he
texted me yeah it's Joey Diaz man sorry
folks wish I could let yin you can go
google what he said I'm trying to be
respectful it it's Joey Diaz there he
can say whatever he wants he doesn't
work for the UFC he's not he's not at
your attorney right I'm glad he does
I glad he does think like that okay send
me text like that but if I was a news
website and I was gonna report out there
first of all you want me please read
yeah
let cliff for sure that's what they want
but also anybody who reads that I really
you're either gonna be like me or you
like you're gonna start laughing what so
you're gonna get really upset really
upset and you're not a Joey Diaz fan
anyway you know if you read that in 95
percent of that is dudes reading are
like that's hilarious
yeah the other 5% of like what the hell
what are we doing how could you report
this yeah I think that's a good number
95 95 dude that's hilarious
I was wondering the same thing some
women will get upset though and rightly
so if I have just to imagine if you were
a dude and there was some big ol giant
Alexander Karelin looking dude who
wanted to [ __ ] you and he was always
making jokes but what your butthole must
smell like just stop just stop and think
of what that would feel like that
wouldn't be a good time if you're
McKenzie if you're anybody that someone
is saying those things about right
I just mean just trying to be
open-minded social justice I'm [ __ ]
out I come out it's not possible I just
I feel sick but what I'm saying is if
you look at it from the position of my
right as a person the person whose
butthole is in question that would be an
uncomfortable position to be in
right a bunch of people talking about
what your butthole smelled like we just
trying to make a living on TV just
trying to make a living just try to
choke a girl you know what that it's
it's also Joey Diaz being complimentary
you know it'd be one thing if she was
not an attractive female or something
like that she's obviously very
attractive which is what makes us funny
I agree 100%
I agree now if you tweets out I want to
wet black beasts [ __ ] smells like
something like that totally redeemed
that's funny too he might
yeah I don't know if he can get away
with that you know I just - throw it up
there to give those cheeto fingers
something to write about Joey's coming
on with Yoel Romero
I cannot wait for that I cannot it's
give me a complete it's the craziest
podcast ever they're gonna talking in
Cuban and I mean Spanish obviously then
go back and forth trans little English
and whatever whatever he can't get
Joey's gonna help him out with you know
like if I'm if I talk too fast or if I
say something and doesn't understand
Joey's gonna jump in and it's gonna be
awesome
it could be awesome a complete [ __ ] Joe
that's right be awesome yeah see me
awesome with you and Joey well Joey's
just he's a great entertainer our people
don't understand like part of the reason
why he's so funny is he knows what's
entertaining for you Kirk he knows he
knows how to be the life of the party
like like no one counts pretty goddamn
good at it Callens up the calicut
entertainment room talent can take over
a room and and some of the best party I
think that's his best art form me titli
I've told him that I think that your
best art form is like inappropriate
comedy around people who are trapped
correctly you're out a plane with him or
something and he can't go anywhere it's
the funniest person he's made me laugh
harder offstage that almost anybody yeah
he's right there he's right up there
offstage with Joey but on stage Joey's
just he's on different handle especially
right now he's on another planet
[Applause]